this video is sponsored by Morgan and
Morgan 92 percent of Americans drive
cars of that number 77 percent of
drivers have experienced at least one
car wreck in their life now I'm not
trying to scare anybody but the fact is
that car crashes often come with
injuries sustained by our bodies in
addition to our cars now you guys need
to be driving safely out there but what
if God forbid something does happen on
the road where would that leave you
physically or financially fortunately
for all of us we live in a day and age
where technology makes getting help
easier than ever and that's where
today's sponsor America's largest injury
Law Firm Morgan and Morgan can come to
our rescue they have over a hundred
offices and 800 lawyers Across the
Nation who have altogether recovered 15
billion dollars for their clients but
talking to lawyers is scary right wrong
it used to be but talking to Morgan and
Morgan these days is more like ordering
a pizza through an app on your phone so
if you're ever injured in an accident
you can check out Morgan and Morgan it's
super easy and you can actually submit
an entire claim in eight clicks or less
without even leaving your couch for more
information go to forthepeople.com slash
Bandit or dial pound law from your cell
phone this has been a paid advertisement
and now on to the video Zelda and
dungeons go hand in hand or at least
they used to nowadays I guess it's more
along the lines of Zelda and Chica
structures but classic Zelda dungeons
have always been a staple of the series
and when it jumped to 3D with the
release of Ocarina of Time the potential
of dungeons exploded exponentially into
the third dimension fast forward a few
years and the world was blessed with the
release of The Legend of Zelda The Wind
Waker which came with its own set of
dungeons that might I add each featured
a fresh new take on puzzles and themes
but you know there's like one two three
there's like nine dungeons in the game
11 if you count some islands as many
dungeons with there being so many I
decided I'd reach out to Mr Wind Waker
himself and see if he'd like to help out
with explaining the lore Behind These
dungeons I'm Celtic and I love Wind
Waker seriously it's my favorite game in
the series so I jumped at the chance to
join bandits in discussing its dungeons
as usual we're going to cover half of
the dungeons in this video and the
remaining half in zeltics video over on
his channel so be sure to head over
there after you're done here or hello if
you're coming here from there oh and
spoiler alert obviously the first
dungeon we're going to cover in this
video would be the first dungeon in the
game The Forsaken Fortress in Japanese
it's called the majuto which means demon
Beast Island however the first time link
visits the island stronghold it
functions more like a mini dungeon than
a full-fledged one but for those who
have played Wind Waker before you'll
remember that the Forsaken Fortress Is
visited multiple times in the game with
the second visit meeting the full
criteria for being considered an actual
Zelda dungeon the role that the Fortress
plays in the game is a relatively simple
one it's the base of operations for the
resurrected Ganondorf and his minions
their living quarters and even a kitchen
can be found within the walls of the
fort The Fortress is made of Hardy stone
walls adorned with hanging ship anchors
and is armed with cannons that will fire
upon any vessel unfortunate enough to be
discovered by its many searchlights Atop
The Fortress is a broken ship within
which Ganondorf himself resides the
stronghold is also home to the Fearsome
helmerok King who lived to serve
ganondorf's every command early on in
the game it's discovered that this
monstrous bird had been making
appearances all over the world
kidnapping young girls with long ears
and as link Ventures throughout the
Forsaken fortress's many rooms it's
uncovered on his second visit that the
kidnapped girls are actually being held
captive on the island as well meaning
the Fortress also functions as a prison
it's also here that link is finally
reunited with his sister arrow and is
able to rescue her from whatever fate
Ganondorf had in store for the girls his
motivation for kidnapping girls with
long ears was to locate the Triforce of
wisdom which was split apart from the
completed Relic long ago in the events
of Ocarina of Time as you no doubt were
aware far beneath the surface of the
great sea lies the ancient and legendary
land of Hyrule itself where Ganondorf
the Triforce and the history of the
Legend of Zelda originated and it is
likely that the Forsaken Fortress is
actually found directly above hyrule's
Gerudo desert region although for a bit
more detail into the thought process
behind that ganon's Tower and the Unseen
history of ganondorf's Resurrection in
the adults timeline you'll have to check
out the video over on my channel after
we're done here Ganondorf accurately
assumed that the piece of wisdom was
under the protection of a descendant of
Zelda and it's for this reason that he
commanded the helmerok king to hunt down
and capture every girl that could
possibly fit the criteria for that era's
Zelda after link returns to the Fortress
and defeats the helmerok king Ganondorf
reveals that the master sword has long
since lost its evil cleansing ability
and as such is powerless against him as
well as the fact that the drawing of the
master sword has unlocked his own full
power from being frozen in time in
Hyrule Castle but just before he is able
to capture link and the real Zelda
otherwise known as the pirate Queen
Tetra the Rito along with Valu the
dragon arrive and rescue the duo from
ganon's grass burning his chamber to a
crisp following these events though
Ganondorf and his minions actually leave
The Forsaken Fortress leaving it eerily
empty save for a few rats and keys the
only purpose The Fortress serves in the
game following this is to allow link and
the king of Red Lions easy access to and
from ganon's Castle in Hyrule via the
dark portal that Ganondorf originally
used to enter the world above the sea
but let's move on or back up I guess the
next dungeon to cover would be the
Forbidden Woods located right next to
the Forest Haven which famously houses
the great Deku Tree and little koroks
the Deku Tree has forbidden this
neighboring area from the koroks due to
the dangerous wildlife lurking inside
but of course one korok in particular
named Makar decided to not heed the
dekatri's warning and instead fly over
the woods and then fall into them since
the woods are not accessible from the
ocean below the Deku Tree has to provide
link with a Deku Leaf at this time and
it's with this that link is able to fly
across the sea using Cyclones for an
updraft and Enter The Forbidden Woods
clearing it of monsters and rescuing
Makar at long last after which the duo
leaves the woods and the area is never
referred to again in the game with the
little amount of time we spend here and
the scarcity of mentions of the
Forbidden Woods in general we instead
have have to look at its appearance and
location for some environmental
deductions regarding the lore behind
this dungeon for starters I always found
it very interesting how similar The
Forbidden Woods are to the Forest Haven
proper both are large tree trunks with
hollowed-out interiors that lead to
different chambers within which entire
ecosystems of wildlife exist this leads
me to believe that both the Forbidden
Woods and the Forest Haven are a similar
kind of giant tree trunk and must have
both been created out of a similar
method however obviously the Forbidden
Woods has become overgrown with
dangerous and downright mean looking
Thorns that almost completely encase the
trunk while that is interesting enough
it's what we can find inside the woods
that really makes this area stand out
see on each of the doors within the
dungeon we can find the crest of the
Kokiri as well as torches pots little
houses and even moving platforms all of
which imply that the area used to be
inhabited by none other than the Kokiri
tribe as the Deku Tree States the Kokiri
are the ancestors of the koroks so the
Woods's proximity to the Forest Haven
makes sense as that's where the koroks
currently live perhaps the forbidden
Woods actually used to be the Lost Woods
which similarly neighbored the Kokiri
Forest which is most likely the Forest
Haven these days and which the Kokiri
lived in and around in Ocarina of Time
the biggest two questions to tackle
though are one why are the woods encased
in a giant tree trunk similar to the
Forest Haven and two what happened to
the woods that caused them to be
corrupted by dangerous wildlife and
Chase the Kokiri out let's tackle the
first question first it's a fair
assumption made by most that the Forest
Haven is entirely made out of the wood
of the Deku Tree after all the Deku Tree
is a giant tree and is housed directly
in the center of the Haven and while I
do think the Forest Haven is located
here above the land beneath the waves as
a result of the Deku Tree I'd like to
propose that the Deku Tree might have
been able to cause the giant trees of
the Forest Haven and now the Forbidden
Woods to rise above the surface of the
water in order to protect not only the
Kokiri Forest and the Lost Woods but the
Kokiri themselves following the flooding
of the old world since wind waker's
great Deku Tree is more than likely the
same Deku Tree that appeared to the hero
of time as a spray route which we can
induce by the fact that it immediately
starts speaking ancient Hylian upon
seeing Link's green clothes and the fact
that this is in the adult timeline
within which the Sprout exists then the
Deku Tree having a tree terraforming
ability if you will is the only
explanation for both of these islands in
my opinion now as far as the corruption
of the Lost Woods into the modern
Forbidden Woods is concerned we actually
do have decently concise proof that this
is the work of Ganondorf you know
besides the obvious Trope of evil man
did all the evil things the boss of the
Forbidden Woods the kaleidemos is a
giant carnivorous plant that clearly is
a deadly mutation of a bokobaba but if
we fast forward for two seconds and take
a sneak peek at the final dungeon of the
game ganon's Castle located far beneath
the great sea we once again face the
bosses that Ganon is credited with
creating one of which is the kalei demos
which has its own boss room in the tower
proving that the Kali demos was a
creation of Ganon and implying heavily
that the thorns and downright unfriendly
atmosphere are also a result of this
corruption which led the Kokiri to leave
of the woods and take shelter instead
directly around the Deku Tree on the
main Forest Haven island perhaps
Ganondorf tainted the Lost Woods in an
attempt to eliminate the Kokiri and
possibly even the Deku Tree as well in
order to kill or flesh out the hero
since his previous encounter with the
hero of time who came from the Kokiri
Forest probably left a bad taste in his
mouth for the area ultimately Ganondorf
was unable to predict that the next hero
would originate from The Humble outset
Island which would eventually prove to
be his fatal mistake next up we have the
wind temple one of two ancient temples
created for the two new sages of Earth
and wind to conduct their prayers to the
Gods in order to maintain the master
swords evil repelling power however
Ganondorf personally attacked and killed
both sages and this is why he knew the
master sword's power had depleted when
link tried to confront him Atop The
Forsaken Fortress leading Link in the
king of Red Lions to seek out the living
descendants of the deceased sages in
order to awaken them and empower the
master sword once again interestingly
enough even though the ancient
structures were built in Hyrule below
both temples were created within
mountains that had accessible entrances
located on their mountaintops sealed
away to prevent any unwanted explorers
this would imply that the Architects had
foreknowledge of hyrule's eventual
flooding since the Mountaintop entrances
are the very methods link must use to
access the temples long after Hyrule has
been sealed away underneath the great
sea the design of the wind Temple is
difficult to grasp since it includes
many platforms and giant fans including
the biggest one located in the central
cylindrical room but nothing we can see
within the temple implies it had any
Grand purpose outside of being a series
of physical puzzles and challenges not
unlike most other Dungeons and the
sheikah shrines from breath of the wild
many of which also feature giant fans
and wind current parents the only fair
assumption behind the wind Temple's
design would be to throw off possible
Intruders from reaching the Sage's
prayer chamber effectively protecting
the sage and therefore the power of the
master sword since the wind Temple has
been accessed by Ganondorf in order to
kill the sage of wind it's now home to
many monsters which presumably were not
present previously such as the boss of
the temple the flying sand monster known
as mulgura there are a few enemies in
the area that may have had other Origins
such as the armos and armos knight
statue monsters but that's a theory for
another day in order to access the wind
Temple link must find a way to approach
the octarok statue that's blowing harsh
winds out of its mouth preventing
entrants to do this link has to travel
to the ice ring aisle a strange little
island that's permanently encased in a
Sub-Zero environment and serves as a
mini dungeon that must be complete in
five minutes or less after temporarily
warming the temperature of the aisle
with a fire arrow after entering the
aisle through its dragon-like mouth
entrance and carefully Crossing its icy
platforms link is rewarded with the iron
boots as some fans will remember this is
quite similar to the iron boots that the
hero of time is able to find in Ocarina
of Time After venturing through the Ice
Cavern which is a remarkably similar
setup to what happens in this game the
only connections between the two events
however are speculative at best but it
is interesting that the key piece of
equipment needed to access the wind
Temple is hidden away within the ice
ring aisle which the dragon sculptures
might suggest is man-made since the iron
boots clearly placed inside the ice ring
aisle purposefully are necessary for
entrance to the wind Temple's
Mountaintop opening it's possible that
the two locations share the same
creators the exact same setup happens
with Fire Mountain but I'll let you
guess which video you can check out for
a deeper look there once link has the
iron boots in hand rather in feet he can
then approach the wind octorock statue
without flying away and destroy it with
the skull hammer but upon entering the
chamber behind the statue is greeted
with a stone tablet and a spirit of a
kakiri which are not present in the game
the kakiri speaks to link revealing his
name as Fado the ancestor of Makkah the
korok he was one of two sages killed by
Ganondorf in order to sap the master
sword of its power not only does this
prove the blood connection between the
forest dwelling kakiri and korok spirits
but it also reveals to link that Fado
does indeed have a living descendant
Makkah who link needs to find and help
awaken as the new Sage of wind in order
to empower the blade of Evil's Bane once
again oddly enough the other awakened
sage in the game is medley the Rito who
as you know a race of flying bird-like
people yet medley is awakened as the
sage of Earth and not wind while Makkah
is awakened as wind instead of Earth if
we recall that the forest and wind
elements are often linked in Zelda games
makkah's wind Sage connection makes more
sense but that's neither here nor there
the wind Temple and its Sage likely
contributed to embodying the essence of
Swift wind-like Justice to be carried
out by the sword and its chosen hero and
the trees and plants life within the
temples symbolize the life that the hero
is sworn to protect as opposed to the
essence of death which permeates the
walls of the Earth Temple
the last dungeon we'll cover in this
video is by far the shortest of them all
I mean the entire thing is one room but
it's also by far the most intriguing the
Ghost Ship which appears in an eerie
storm at night in different locations
across the Great Sea depending on the
shape of the Moon surrounded by floating
Spirit flames and emitting a strange
chant has forever haunted my yearning to
understand the lore of the zaudi
universe as well as my nightmares
super hardcore vintage fans of my
channel here might remember that long
ago I had an entire theory about this
very same ship and I'm here to tell you
today that what I'll say in this video
will differ slightly if you're
interested in my full earlier more
speculative thoughts on the strange
vessel though feel free to check that
video out the Ghost Ship plays a crucial
role in the game in that link absolutely
must not only track down and discover
the ship itself but also figure out how
to board and access it in order to
complete the game if link approaches the
Ship Without first obtaining its Ghost
Ship chart The Vessel will simply
disappear once link gets too close in
order to obtain the Ghost Ship chart
though link has to travel to the diamond
step Island and descend underneath it
where he's met with another chilling
scene an entire buried ship graveyard
it's completely unknown how these sea
vessels were buried here but there are
torches spread throughout the area and
magical warping pots that link must use
to navigate The Maze of ship corpses in
order to find the chest containing the
Ghost Ship chart there are also several
Floormasters in the area that will
return link to the beginning of the
amazed if he's unfortunate enough to get
caught this all heavily implies that
whoever did this whoever buried these
vessels here and constructed the Maze
and hid the ghost chart did so on
purpose and automatically because of the
direct connection between this graveyard
and the ominous Ghost Ship itself I
think it's very plausible that whoever
made this area is also responsible for
the existence of the Ghost Ship after
link retrieves the chart and therefore
is able to hunt down and approach the
ship he's mysteriously transported into
its interior without actually having to
climb aboard and once inside it's clear
that wherever link is is not of the
Mortal realm huge tears in the ship's
frame can be seen yet instead of seeing
the night sky or sea water on the
outside of the ship we can see countless
ghosts swarming around the outside there
are a few enemies inside the boat two
pose and a wizrobe all of which have
connections to reanimated dead once
they're all defeated though link is able
to climb a ladder and retrieve either a
Triforce Chart or an actual Shard of the
Triforce depending on which version of
the game you play one of the creepiest
features of the Ghost Ship would be the
strange portrait located above the
treasure which Bears a wide menacing
grin towards link that disappears
whenever he gets close after looting the
chest for the Triforce a ghostly scream
can be heard and Link immediately passes
out and reawakens aboard the king of red
lions with the Ghost Ship forever Fading
Into non-existence now obviously due to
the nature of such a dungeon the Ghost
Ship must be explained with some large
degree of theoretical analysis which
isn't explicitly proven in game meaning
you are more than welcome to believe
what you would like to instead if you so
choose but I think it's quite likely
that since the breaking apart and hiding
of the shards of the Triforce of Courage
was something ordained by the kingdom of
Hyrule long ago when the hero of time
left the timeline the Ghost Ship hiding
one of these shards is in that case
something the Hylian specifically
planned and executed I think it's quite
likely that given the at least three
ships located in the ship graveyard and
the countless Souls surrounding the
Ghost Ship the ship may actually be the
culmination of the spirits of hyrule's
ancient Navy who used to Pilot those
ships in the graveyard who all gave
their lives in order to hide one of the
shards from ganondorf's grasp in their
Undead servitude however they had to
come up with some kind of method for
discovering The Shard should the hero
arise once again and have need of it
hence the carefully crafted ship
graveyard maze perhaps it's even the
Triforce Shard itself that's able to
keep the ghosts alive and that's why
when link obtains it they're able to
finally move on from this realm and as
they do so they emit one last chilling
scream before disappearing forever and
that wraps up this half of wind waker's
dungeon lore except for that creepy face
above the ghost ship's Treasure Chest
who knows why it grins from ear to ear
thanks Bandit for having me on to talk
wind waker if you'd like more analysis
check out the counterpart video over on
my channel where we'll dive into
dungeons like the Earth Temple and Tower
of the Gods cheers thank you guys so
much for watching and an enormous Thanks
goes to Celtic for not only joining me
in this video but helping with the
theories and analyzes of the dungeons
please consider leaving a like on the
video If you enjoyed it or at least our
efforts into making it and subscribe if
you haven't already for much more gaming
lore with Metroid on the way hint hint
huge thanks as always to my banner crew
who are the reason I keep going with the
channel and by the way I'm looking
forward to seeing some of you at Pax
right now actually that's all I've got
for this one so follow me on my socials
and I'll see you in a sec over on
zeltic's channel for the rest of the
dungeons this is Bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
[Music]
foreign